come now speak your mind
I've spent around 20 hours playing
destiny to covering the majority of the
story missions dozens of site activities
a strike in a handful of rounds in the
crucible I still have a lot more to go
and I'll be documenting my progress over
the next few days as I play more so far
destiny two builds on the original and
smart ways that make me excited to keep
playing I was expecting my first
impression of destiny too was that it
was barely distinguishable from the
first game the things I loved about
destiny the exhilaration of nailing a
precision kill the satisfaction of
shooting each weapon felt the same as
did the repetitive feeling I didn't like
as much but the more I played the more I
noticed that some of Destiny's other
problems have been fixed I haven't
finished the main story yet but so far
it's a clear improvement from Destiny's
much-maligned storytelling I've heard
quite a few new voices over the comms
lately all Thorne says we have you to
thank for that it's a good thing too
while you were gallivanting about the
system matters not a bit sticky here in
the dead zone if you've got a moment we
have plenty of things that need doing
like the beta destiny 2 begins with an
attack on the tower by a cabal faction
called the red Legion but rather than
being thrust into situations with little
to no context as was so often the case
in destiny each mission of the red war
arc has objectives that make sense both
in the mission itself and within the
grand scheme locating a missing cayde-6
for example is important to the fight
against the red Legion since he's a
powerful hunter but fighting waves of
vex to get to him also makes sense as
he's trapped in a vex teleporter and
that small bit of context makes killing
the same enemies in that moment feel
distinct your ghost also does a better
job of introducing you to enemies like
the fallen and Becks provided you didn't
port your character over from destiny in
which case the dialogue is supposed to
be different though we haven't tested it
yet as for you Guardian well done if
that brute had gotten loose with the
Saiyans there may have been no stopping
it
and then I couldn't not collect it on
that fat they can take it destiny has
some fascinating and complicated lore
and giving you the foundation necessary
to understand it works in destiny two's
favor that goes well in tandem with
destiny two's new and improved patrol
zones there are four new destinations
earth to European dead zone
Nessus Titan and IO when you touch down
you have a lot more options for what to
do and it's surprising how far that goes
toward breaking up the repetition you
can do a regular quick and dirty patrol
or you can embark on a longer adventure
mission completing a series of
objectives for better rewards there are
also the new lost sectors which are
essentially dungeons and forego
structured objectives for bosses and
loot chests both adventures and lost
sectors take you to far-flung areas of
the map and often include a healthy bit
of backstory because of that it feels
like you're doing something of substance
rather than a series of menial tasks one
adventure had me setting up comms for
Refugees at the last city which then led
me to fighting off a horde of fallen
that we're jamming the signals it felt
more important than just killing a
fallen leader in some random area of the
map with no purpose other than to get XP
inevitably and now we know that there
are resources to be found in the e DZ
once we retake the city that'll be a big
help sure what's Araya means to say is
thank you my favorite change though is a
small one that greatly impacted how I
play the old up in categories primary
special and heavy have been replaced by
kinetic energy and power weapons are
sorted a bit differently and formerly
primary weapons can show up in both your
kinetic and energy slots kinetics have
no special attributes while energy
weapons can take on the ark solar or
void energies and are better for taking
down enemies shield for me this meant
switching my weapon more based on the
situation and using weapons I never used
a destiny one I already love the
feedback loop of Destiny's shooting in
spongy enemies and that small bit of
variety made me love it even more of
course all of this still feels like
destiny the new social space the farm is
functionally the same as the tower in
the original finding loot in switch
your old gear still takes up a
significant portion of your time enemies
have been tweaked but they're not wildly
different either that's not necessarily
bad but it also makes me wonder if I'll
see destiny 2 is a sequel rather than a
half step up the longer I play and the
more I grind and repeat because my time
with the game began prior to launch at a
Bungie event I'm starting fresh at
launch like everyone else
after I've caught up to my previous
progress I can finally look forward to
finishing the campaign and seeing how
the story works out of course I also
need to spend a significant amount of
time with strikes the crucible and
eventually the raid in short there's a
lot of destiny too left to play before I
can deliver my final review until then
checking a spot every day for a brief
look at my progress and thoughts on
destiny - as I go picking up a big spike
in Polish adder you sound pretty pissed
I think we can handle whatever they
throw as they deploy the Walker to your
position